Nyko Hamilton author of American Caesars
you have spent a lifetime thinking about
and practicing the art of biography this
book is among other things maybe a group
biography of the last 12 American
presidents what do you think a
biographer owes his subject I think the
first thing he owes is truth also I
think he owes or she a degree of
curiosity I think it's fatal for the
biographer to go into a project with a
set opinion I think a biographer needs
to have an open mind and clearly you
need some driving interest curiosity but
I think you've got to be willing to
change your mind if the facts and the
documents or the interviews you do lead
you to a different view of the of the
character and that happens several times
in in American ceases it what I get
revived it doesn't biographer also owe
his subject empathy and I mean by that
that's a word that's become almost a
pejorative in some quarters in this town
I mean that a biographer is engaged in
the almost godlike presumptuous act of
recreating life and and if you're going
to explain another human being and his
character and his motivations as well as
his actions presumably you need to try
to step into his shoes perhaps even
inside his skin is that is that
something that you think is is is
necessary I don't know that I would say
necessary because it depends what kind
of biography you want to write
personally I have always until now
avoided writing biographies about people
I don't like because I think as you say
it's difficult to empathize with them
and then you you may end up judging them
unfairly or not being able to put
yourself in their shoes
but if you do have to write about people
you don't necessarily care for and in
this book among the twelve presidents
there were several I write basically
didn't like I think you you owe it to
them I don't know where their empathy is
the right word but you owe it to them to
to try and keep an open mind and at
least intellectually be able to put to
project onto them and of course a big
challenge with American Caesars was to
see them not necessary as domestic
presidents but as Caesars as the most
powerful men in the world and how they
responded to that challenge which had
never existed before the Second World
War
well what's back up a bit we have a very
literate audience here at c-span but for
those who don't know tell us who is
Suetonius and the inspiration in terms
of classical literature for this book
well Gaius tranquillus Suetonius was a
Roman historian at the time of the of
Hadrian who was working in Rome in the
Caesar archives and who got this idea
that he'd like to write the lives of the
great Roman dictators or Caesars from
Julius Caesar onwards and he chose the
first twelve from Julius Caesar through
two Domitian many of them assassinated
and some of them terrible tyrants and
dictators some of them great men like
Caesar Augustus and that book that he
wrote became tremendous and and since
printing began has never been out of
print it is basically our source
material not only on for the lives of
those great Roman emperors but for the
characters the personalities because he
being in Rome he was able to do
interviews with people with who'd
actually lived through some of the lives
of those si
and by telling not only their their
public lives but their private lives he
gave this unforgettable inside this
window onto the world of Rome at the
height of the Roman Empire
it says so so when witnessed Ricci is
often creditors in somebody's the father
of modern a psychological
character-driven biography in fact he
had a classical walk president yeah yes
that's true but the big the big
difference I think is that
Suetonius did something that has never
been done since as far as I know as a
biographical historian and I don't know
if my book is the first time it's been
tried since Roman times but Suetonius
decided to write about those Emperor's
first in terms of how they became
president of Caesar and how they
operated a Caesar and only then to look
at their private lives so he separated
the public from the private now over the
last few centuries we've become more and
more interested in the psychology of
human being so certainly every biography
I've written whether of JFK or Clinton
or bill Marshal Montgomery or whatever
I've always tried to lace into an
understanding of the character right
from the very beginning almost before
he's born an understanding of the
context and the psychology the parents
though the upbringing and civil and when
I was asked if I would like to to write
a new version of the Americans of the
Roman Caesars the twelve Caesars I
looked back to Suetonius and I thought I
tried to analyze how he had structured
his lives and I really liked that
template that idea that you first look
at the public life so that you can
actually see clearly the the political
challenges and the administrative
challenges the leadership challenges
that those men faced in in
a time when they were Caesars and only
then look at their private lives and so
I wrote her an initial chapter on Harry
Truman and showed it to my editor and he
said well you know this works
marvelously you first see him as
president you first see him in the way
that he had to deal with these
extraordinary responsibilities on the
death of Roosevelt and how he dealt with
and only then do you stop and look at
him in terms of his personality that is
current to him I mean in a sense you do
in effect deprive the reader of a sense
of a life being lived evolving growing
reacting and and and all of that pre
story if you will shaping the individual
who who comes into office it's so it's
an anti psychological approach at least
in the early part of the life and then
coming about but the advantage as I say
is if you're looking at a political
figure and if you're interested in the
history of the United States as an
empire since World War two
when it abandoned isolationism I think
it serves to clarify the issues with
which these great presidents for most
part had to deal there's a statistic
that is jaw-dropping
early in the book I think I've got this
right in 1938 the United States
responsible for 14 overseas military
installations today that number exceeds
1,000 how did we get from right how we
got from 14 well that is the story of
the American Empire and the United
States I think was like 17th in terms of
the military ranking before World War
two the army was desperately
understaffed and how much of that though
was the result of disillusionment
following World War one that were what
had been in effect sold to the American
people as a as a crusade absolutely
absolutely it was the same in Britain in
fact John F Kennedy wrote his thesis at
Harvard that was made into a book why
England slept England slept because he
didn't want to know any more about
armaments and the tragedy of World War
one
but once the Japanese attacked at Pearl
Harbor the the whole scenario changed
and what I found is so fascinating
looking back at FDR was the way that the
United States geared itself up so
incredibly quickly to fighting not only
a world war but a world war on two
vastly separated fronts in the Pacific
and and in Europe it's interesting
because well first of all will you
acknowledge of it there were would be
candidates for a Caesar before FDR and
would with Teddy Roosevelt be a an
imperial figure yes Woodrow Wilson
certainly there were characters who who
were would be Caesars and in many I
think often they were referred to but
very quickly the that notion of the
United States becoming a pseudo monarchy
or Empire was was abandoned and it is
only with World War two that the United
States forever abandons isolation and
the real reason is the atomic bomb
you know once the United States had
developed the atomic weapon it was I
mean people talked about disarmament but
I mean the thought that you could disarm
and somebody else would have the bomb
was just enormous
so really out of necessity the United
States became not only a competent in
world war ii but the great democratic
hegemony of the post-war and i'm
wondering you're a native brit does that
give you a particular insight into the
Imperial mindset and and in fact one of
the was not one of the factors of the
American Century post-war the the
relative withdrawal of Britain from that
role absolutely I don't think I could
have written a book I certainly wouldn't
have had the arrogance
to undertake it because a lot of people
civil nitrile isn't this rather
ambitious I had written quite deeply
about to American president JFK and Bill
Clinton yeah what make sure our viewers
know I you've written about young JFK a
book was certainly stirred fair about a
controversy and a two-volume biography
of Bill Clinton including the Clinton
presidency and of course in your
multi-volume biography of managua
Montgomery you certainly met up with
Dwight Eisenhower so so you brought all
of that into this enterprise so I felt I
had a sort of handle but as you say the
real advantage I felt I had in relation
to my colleagues in the United States
who teach history was that I had
actually grown up in a decaying British
Empire you know I've born in 1944 you
know Churchill was still dreaming of
holding on to India African colonies and
so forth I mean one of the most
fascinating things about FDR in my
chapter is the way that FDR basically
tells Churchill that it's no good yeah
it's interesting you put try others have
have hinted at this but you portrayed
Churchill now with all of his heroic
qualities
well Hydra than life qualities is
essentially a man looking over his
shoulder and FDR is someone with a surer
grasp of the future that has yet to
unfold
I think FDR was a real visionary
domestically but also globally he's
definitely the hero of this book can be
and that breeze of coming out because we
have 12 figures and it's interesting
that the first for Roosevelt Truman
Eisenhower and Kennedy are the great
Caesars in your view exactly and and of
course that raises the question is it
what happened post Kennedy - I mean has
it all been downhill is it been the
nature of the Empire or the imperial
exercise itself
it was Vietnam was it individual
presidents coincidence bad what what
what combined to trace this trajectory
from FDR to the present well the short
answer be all of the above but I do
think the big turning point was Lyndon
Johnson and the Vietnam War and in a
sense that's the most tragic chapter in
the book you see Johnson as a tragic
figure absolutely because he was a man
who raised in the south in Texas who
hadn't shown any particular enthusiasm
for civil rights but who then took up
that mantle of civil rights reform and
basically rammed it down the throats of
Congress and certainly southern
politicians and who knew that it might
be fatal for the chances of Democratic
candidates in the future and I think he
showed enormous courage in that sense
and there is a wonderful moment which I
hadn't come across before when in 1964
when he was still an unelected president
he'd simply assumed the mantle after the
assassination of JFK there's a moment
when he drafts a letter of resignation
of saying to say that he would not stand
for the presidency at the National
Convention and people were so worried
about senator Goldwater and the
Republican right that he was almost
pressed into service but its intranet
well he had mine well oh yes I think he
may have had it in mind but I think it's
just interesting that you know in a way
if he had stood aside he would have had
to be in this book as one as the fifth
great president because what he achieved
with civil rights really was
extraordinary and and he inherited
Kennedy's
involvement in Vietnam it wasn't a war
at that stage and though and I think in
many ways although a great man Johnson
was not equipped to be a Caesar you know
he had traveled somewhat around the
world as vice president and but he
essentially his realm was the United
States he's his real realm was Texas and
he wasn't real exercising itself yes
exactly and I don't think he he had the
confidence in in the same way as JFK
developed it even though such a young
man I know he had the confidence to over
rule his advisors and to say well
Goldwater may be still pushing from the
right but we won the election and we are
not going to war there like say during
the Tonkin incident you know even wide
your sense you know we all have sort of
a set of criteria for the ideal
president presumably we all want our
presidents to have a sense of history
and the perspective that that that that
brings is it also possible though for
them to become prisoners of history
clearly Lyndon Johnson's generation was
branded by Munich and the Munich analogy
kept surfacing appropriate or otherwise
and in Johnson's case in addition he
also was haunted by the fact that the
right wing had exploited China's going
communist in 1949 he you know he he
recognized that in signing the civil
rights bill
he was probably signing away the south I
mean you just wonder whether all of this
came together to influence in any way
what I disagree with my fellow
historians in who tend to believe in in
movements and patterns that can't be
changed and I think a good example of
rejecting this notion that you're
imprisoned within say the history of
Munich
appeasement of appeasing a dictator or a
threat is the way that President
Eisenhower the third great Caesar in my
view the way that he dealt with the Suez
Crisis in 1956 because the British of
the French and the Israelis went in to
take back the Suez Canal and they
assumed the United States even though
the most powerful country in the world
would along with the CIA would simply
stand back and and say tut-tut naughty
kids and allow it to happen and
Eisenhower did not he's the president of
the United States and he's the
commander-in-chief of the American armed
forces and he said no and he basically
bankrupted the British by saying we're
not going to support the pound sterling
I mean the president is in an
extraordinary way to change history if
he or she one day chooses to do so and I
don't know how his case was interesting
because it's on the eve of the 56
election and he's writing you know in
his private thoughts that this may
actually cost him the election taking a
firm stand will cost the Jewish vote he
can see New York going other other you
know northeastern industrial states so
so from his perspective at the time it
was an act of some political risk on his
part and courage and I think you know
looking across these 12 lives one of the
common themes for those presidents is
definitely courage that's going to ask
you yeah I mean are there themes that
run throughout this period these wives I
mean the themes essential to leadership
under under all circumstances I mean
what do you learn collectively from
these wives if I seen your first two
years in office
well that will probably comes
consolation to the incumbent if you
think of the difficulties almost every
one of these presidents had whether
you're talking about Ray
in their first two years in office it is
this huge learning curve and in that
sense you think well surely there has to
be a better political system that trains
people in advance for this but I don't
know that there is I mean I was
interested in when I was writing about
Bill Clinton and my multi-volume book
that Bill Clinton I'm sure is the the
the cleverest the in intellectually the
smartest with the highest IQ of any
president who's ever occupied the White
House he just has an extraordinary able
mind but in a way he was the worst
president in terms of the Caesars in
terms of taking over the reins of power
once he reached Washington he was
obsessed with the public approval and I
mean you could psychologize that but I
mean the fact was he winning election
was know and know and the other thing he
didn't understand was that you have to
have a terrific chief of staff you know
I spent years as a military historian
recording World War two from Field
Marshal Montgomery's perspective and and
I knew Monti extremely well as a student
and Monty would always say you've got to
have a a good chief of staff and you you
welcome to the bone room and when he
goes mad with all the work you'll toss
him out and you take on another one you
know I you know it's interesting you say
that because it's two presidents well
this this issue arises again in the Ford
White House where Ford initially with a
congressional mindset has the spokes of
the wheel which clearly does not work
but that doesn't keep Jimmy Carter from
employing it in his presidency and as
you write to it to his detriment and and
Clinton it's like let's hope the future
presidents book at least learn some of
the lessons because they're so obvious
it's not a it's not as though you know
it has to yes it's always going to be a
learning curve but there are some things
that we can learn
from history and I think the ability to
be a good administrating administrative
chief once you enter the White House is
absolutely crucial and looking at these
past examples it will be useful that is
fascinating because it's probably one of
the least taught aspects of the
presidency we we were so enamored of the
advocacy role of the presidency the
Harry Truman's notion about public
persuasion is that the chief power the
president setting the agenda using the
media that the unglamorous aspects of
actually making the White House let
alone the country function are often
overlooked
what again you know one of the my
changes of mind is a biographical
historian was Ronald Reagan in this book
because I had been brought up in in the
United Kingdom where I was there when
Reagan was president and Reagan was
considered by my colleagues to be my
joke I mean they didn't know really much
about him as governor of California and
they didn't nobody had any idea that his
political convictions went so deep and
so far back into his career and I ended
up having didn't always agree with him
but I had ended up having enormous
admiration first of all for the depth of
his assurance that communism could be
confronted from an economic point of
view
and that the Soviet Union could finally
be brought down by economic competition
but the other thing I admired him for
was his temperament we haven't talked
about that but I think one of the themes
that runs through the book is that
certain presidents did have the right
kind of temperament
be a Caesar and I ask you because on the
other surface if you're talking about
self-confidence conviction to however
you want to call it Jimmy Carter had no
lack of self-confidence Ronald Reagan
had no lack of self-assurance but two
very different presidencies right I
don't think you self-confidence is the
right that's necessarily the right
requirement now I'm talking about
temperament such as JFK showed the
ability to distance yourself a little
bit to stand back you know the looking
at the way JFK handled the Cuban Missile
Crisis to listen to the advice you're
getting from your cabinet and your
national security advisers but to be
able to filter that through your own
mind as an independent mind and to
remember that you were elected by the
people of the United States not by these
people sitting around the cave table and
you owe your loyalty to them I think
that was is vitally important and I'm
not sure Jimmy Carter really had that he
had this absolute sincerity and a
visionary quality I mean that he saw the
challenges that the United States was
until a cup at rate ISM so to speak
belief in the national interest on the
contrary you know he believed that so
deeply but the problem was he believed
it so deeply that he wasn't listening to
the other people and but but you you you
quote him and I think early on is
telling someone that he hoped to have a
relationship establish relationship with
the Soviet Union akin to our
relationship with Great Britain yes I
mean he would come out with these
remarkably naive notions which in a way
were very Christian very charitable they
lacked a certain realism if you're going
to be emperor of the United States well
I keep saying Empire
you know Americans here do not like to
consider themselves an empire hey we got
rid of the British we don't want to go
back there surely we don't see ourselves
as no only old power right but abroad
that is exactly how the United States is
seen if anybody travels outside the
United States they very quickly become
aware of that and as you said earlier on
the number of military bases well over a
thousand well well over a thousand you
means that the United States is
operating at a military level that has
never existed in the history of humanity
and we're not even the Romans were as
powerful as that in their time so you
know it's a it's a huge challenge you
it's interesting I mean there's so many
interesting things in this book up I I
think it's fair to say it's a
revisionist history in a number of
number of respects for example running
one of the threads that runs throughout
the story of the last 70 years is
America in the Middle East and
particularly our relationship where
there was Israel and you write most most
of his admirers would would point to the
Camp David Accords as perhaps the
highlight of of Carter's presidency and
you you present that in a very different
light yes I presented in Jimmy Carter's
retrospective life light he came to
think at the time he was very proud of
it after all he brought these sworn
enemies from Egypt in Israel together
and they'd come to a peace agreement and
the Israelis were going to withdraw from
some of the occupied territories but
over the years he felt that he got the
poor end of the stick that the Israelis
had really run rings around him and that
the Israelis have got really everything
they wanted and peace which is what he
really wanted in the Middle East would
probably not happen certainly in his
administration but even after that
and I I know certainly most of my Jewish
friends and colleagues think rather
badly of of Jimmy Carter for that and
I'm I'm sad about that because I he's
certainly not anti-semitic and he's a
brave man who constantly goes over there
I mean he is truly interested in priests
I think I quote an Indian who once said
of him he's the Mahatma Gandhi of modern
times what one has a sense not least of
all from reading your portrait that in
some ways he's him he's a better former
president than him perhaps he was a
president oh I don't think he would
quarrel with that actually oh yes a
great man but not a great Caesar because
you know it's a little bit off the path
but I mean it raises us to me
fascinating question is someone who's
thought about the ex presidency it may
very well be that the largest part of
Curtis legacy is to redefine this
nebulous office which has pluses and
minuses I mean if you look at Bill
Clinton's Center it is as ambitious in
its outreach in various humanitarian
efforts but correct me if I'm wrong
there's not an operational diplomatic
element to what Bill Clinton does
grounded in the resentment that he and
other presidents felt toward Jimmy
Carter who they thought was operating as
a kind of freelancer exactly and it can
be very embarrassing to the incumbent of
President if he feels he's being
overshadowed if he you know the former
president is traveling I think it it
happened when Richard Nixon during
President Ford's time when Richard Nixon
said he was going to to China yeah a
week before they don't Hampshire primary
yes
I mean poor Gerald Ford you know had
good reason to feel wow I gave this man
a pardon which is this was almost the
centerpiece of that chapter I think that
was a terrible mistake but so you are
not in that I think it's probably safe
to say it
full disclosure a lot of c-span audience
knows I was close to president board
that was one of the library's I ran and
we had a personal relationship but I
think it's safe to say he with unlike
Lyndon Johnson he lived long enough to
have the satisfaction of knowing that
most Americans had come to the point of
view that what he did was necessary and
indeed an act of political courage
through the Kennedy Library gave him the
Profiles in Courage Award them sort of
it icing on the cake but but I take it
you you you question that consensus or
you still think that it was a mistake
yes I think it's a terrible mistake and
I think Richard Nixon was one of the
most dangerous president we've ever had
and I think he was truly close to being
a madman and I quote a great it's it you
you can pay above Johnson and Nixon to
Caligula well Johnson in terms of his
private life I mean we haven't mentioned
that but each of these presidents has a
private life or a love life if you like
to call it and they're often at complete
odds would be the public figure and you
have to ask yourself well does the
private life actually impact it raises
that question I mean clearly John
Kennedy behaved recklessly in his
private life but at the time the Cuban
Missile Crisis it was the opposite of
reckless so what is the connect I don't
think you know if I was a psychologist
as sociologist I might try and draw some
statistical influence but I didn't think
it would be worth a damn really I think
the fact is all these ceases were
individuals you need a hell of a lot of
individuality and ambition to get to the
White House they were extraordinary
characters and going through
extraordinary tensions just to get to
the way
later and the responsibilities they
carried and how they manage their
private lives differs from you know one
to the other I mean Harry Truman is the
perfect example of the devoted husband I
love that story that when he's in Berlin
he's about to drop dear Tommy or decide
whether to drop the atomic bomb and he's
put in a villa by the Russians at
Potsdam and this young American officer
infantry officer comes in citizen you
know mr. president is there anything you
need I can get you anything anything you
like women and Truman systems some don't
ever mention that again I married my
sweetheart
I am devoted we are loyal to each other
don't ever speak I mean this he was a
truly honorable husband that tells us
something important about Harry Truman
but is there risk particularly in the
modern culture sort of celebrity-driven
culture with a commander-in-chief really
a celebrity in chief something that
maybe began with JFK that we spend too
much time on our private lives there's a
risk that we do but I am afraid it's a
lost cause I mean try and stop the media
I'm sure exclude Caesar you know try and
tell the media not to concentrate on the
personality and the private life and the
particularly the scandals I mean I've
tried to be you know sir Eternia set the
set the pattern for doing this and I've
tried to be truthful about the private
lives and I've tried to be unlived but
they are in succession pretty
extraordinary the one that most
fascinated me actually was some gloomy
gas Richard Nixon when he was a young
man you see the hardest to know are
these twelve figures I think so because
he was quite a brilliant man but he was
so dark and had these different size
to him I mean he was part liberal part
concern right-wing conservative he was
he we now know from his psychiatrist we
have a have the notes of his
psychiatrist who who said he I think I
quote him saying he was an enigma to
himself and he was an enigma to me and
he was the psychiatrist even Nixon's
first girlfriend he pursued for five
years
mind you she was a Democrat so she met
her father was a police chief and she
said after five years he was still an
enigma to me well at the end of his life
from jonathan Aitken
wrote a sympathetic biography of Nixon
and at the end Nixon says to him well
what have you concluded and a consensus
of in fact I've concluded that you're so
complex that no one who ever understand
you completely and it can said now
you're getting somewhere which goes to
your point that he understood himself as
himself yes he would look apparently
according to the psyche at you look into
the mirror and at one point when he was
suffering a lot of depression and I
think he was vice president and he would
look in the mirror and he said to his
psychiatrist I I don't recognize the man
I see I mean I'm often thought I mean
it's your reaction that the most
remarkable thing about the Nixon
presidency it's not unrelated to what
we're talking about is not how it ended
but then it happened at all oh yes well
and as I say in the book I'm not the
first to say it I think Robert dalek
wrote a wonderful book on this but
basically I think he was guilty of high
treason in sabotaging Johnson's peace
negotiations with North Vietnam but in a
broader said and given his personality
given his you know he said himself I'm
an introvert in an extroverts profession
there are those who regard him as a
closeted intellectual you know who it
wasn't cool you know in his circles for
that to be dull but but he was not a
natural in the Democratic vote seeking
door-knocking
process no but he had yet he and yet he
he reached the the
degree people would you know the secret
of their that he studied acting at
college he he was recognized as a great
Shakespearean potentially great
Shakespearean actor and you see that
when you see the archival film of his
extraordinary like the checkers speech
and those moments when he goes before
the camera and talks about the silent
major majority it talks about his people
his background the people from Witte of
the people and he wasn't that in some
ways a take-off on FDR's version of the
silent majority I mean the the idea that
the little guy hmm who was being
exploited not listened to
punished but in FDR's case it was
idealist I mean to me again that's why I
so admire him there was a man born in
era Scrat who could see beyond his own
circle and and see the the true populace
of the United States but in in Richard
Nixon's case I think it was actually
there was some of that was really
genuine that he came from this I mean
when you go to his little house that's
it that the at the Nixon Library a
combination of idealism and resentments
yes
resentment is terribly important there
he grew up poor you know very early age
brothers dying of tuberculosis is over
and father with this terrible temper and
fearful of the father and so determined
to do well at school to pay he used to
carry his shoes right and in a paper bag
so they would get dirty and going
barefoot to school I mean I think what
would happen in those great moments of
crises when he was accused of corruption
and it looked as though President
Eisenhower would drop him as his or as
nominee
in 1952 that it looked as though Nixon
would have to return with retire or
resign from the vice presidential
nomination and and he goes in front of
the public and gives that checkers
speech but I think that's the moment
when he reaches back into himself and
it's not just resentment it's that
moment when he puts puts away his
political ambitions and all that and he
reaches back into that childhood that's
terribly moving it is moving at it but
at the same time it was a there was a
brilliant piece of theater it gave him
something no vice president in American
history had ever had he had a following
he you know the great ironies later on
Spiro Agnew in effect turn turntables on
on Richard Nixon who made him but
remember at the critical moment in the
kicker speech Ike is watching and people
there they to Nixon ostensibly praising
General Eisenhower and going after
Andrew Stevens oh and calling on
everyone to release their well breaks
his pencil I mean he he knows exactly I
think the instinctive politician who's
spent a lifetime denying he was a
politician knew exactly what was what
was being done to him
yeah yes I mean it's an amazing moment
that is his brilliance his his genius
really
Nixon's that he could turn that kind of
potential defeat into potential victory
by being able to to see other people's
weaknesses
would you buy the notion that Nixon was
in effect the last New Deal president to
some extent yes I would he did believe
in health care reform he did believe in
many public major public initiative and
was some of that accommodating him self
to the prevailing political consensus in
other words 20 years later 25 years
later they're still America was still in
many ways still a New Deal nation I mean
George will famous have said 1980 the
American people are conservative they
want to conserve the New Deal
specifically Social Security is Nixon in
effect like any good politician
accommodating himself to the to the
prevailing consensus Richard I would say
it goes deeper than that I mean again
what moved me was Nixon's absolute
adulation of his mother however a very
religious woman yeah and she never beat
the children but they were terrified of
her calling them out for doing something
sinful or whatever and I think again he
would reach into himself for a notion of
responsibility for society for the less
well-off his mother was a true Christian
in that respect and so yes I I don't
think it was some today will need be a
man without a party oh yes definitely he
wouldn't fit into the current Republican
Party I think very few of these
Republican presidents would actually I
mean you see in almost every case
they're fighting Tea Party style
elements within side of that's an
interesting observation because I wonder
if that's not actually applicable on
both sides of the aisle that you know
FDR had to put up with Huey Long and and
others on the Left who thought he wasn't
people who thought he wasn't decisive
enough this was an opportunity not just
to save capitalism but in some ways at
least for structure if not replace it
Harry Truman talked about professional
liberals John Kennedy had criticism from
the left but so I is it fair to say that
all of these presidents they almost into
the middle they they basically there are
the extremes on the left and the right
and they in the end they're forced into
that middle and what was so interesting
to me is if you exclude to a large
extent the domestic policy side
you see the miracle of how they manage
to deal with that domestic policy side
as best they can but how they still have
the reserves they need and the insights
they need to recognize the a more global
perspective in terms of both American
interests and global global peace I
think you know is it safe to say that
reality intrudes and and an ideology
recedes definitely I think a lot of them
have to take a very deep breath and
basically forget politics or or at least
ideological product politics and and
look at the reality of the situation
it's interesting that John Kennedy is
the fourth of your great Caesars and I'm
wondering because my sense is that Nixon
famously said it would take 50 years
before people could write objectively
about him and the irony is it's I I
would think in 50 years in Kennedy's
case that the deification that followed
the assassination ensured that the
pendulum would swing to the other
extreme and and only now in some ways
that the Kennedy presidency for a long
time we heard one you know he didn't get
much legislation passed style over
substance there was a tendency to
minimize but in fact if you look at the
two overriding issues of the age the
Cold War and civil rights he
demonstrably to use that favorite term
grew in office and in fact before his
death had embraced the politically
difficult position on are both just as
Eisenhower had adopted a more
progressive position on civil rights in
in the previous administration had he as
opposed to enforcing the court order had
he you know in his heart I mean he I he
was very much a graduates who understood
the South or thought he did and who made
the mistake of believing that
southerners would be as good hearted as
he
and that they they could in fact be
educated in a reasonably short period of
time to to a new racial order well I
think you you put your finger in when
you use this word time in in a short
order or a long term yeah because a lot
of these presidents if you put them
together in a room would have very
similar approaches some are very similar
visions in in patriotic terms in terms
of social social responsibility they
would differ in terms of when can this
happen when when when is the great
American public willing to accept this
and in Eisenhower's case obviously he
felt his hand had been forced by the
Supreme Court in terms of schooling and
but he you know he embraced the the
moment and he sent the troops down to
Arkansas and I I think that is a really
salient moment in American history and
the same with John F Kennedy you know he
was concerned that he would get he
should get a second term in office so he
was constantly trying to put things off
to a second term well you know Martin
Luther King and many millions of black
people are not willing to wait for that
and and I think he showed great courage
in in accepting that in facing up to
that but don't you think television
irony JFK has seen is the first
television president someone whose
mastery of the medium in his news
conferences contributed to his legend
second but it was the pictures not only
on the front page of The Times but on
television of kids in Birmingham being
set upon with fire hoses and the like
which in effect to some degree forced
his hand yes Oh photojournalism
definitely changed history in that
respect and that's true of all these
press I mean Eisenhower had accepted
that he had to have training I think he
got training from made morrow Robert
Montgomery
and I think yeah they recognized like we
was saying earlier the bully pulpit and
to be you've got to be a televangelist
that's a fascinating that you mentioned
that because Richard Nixon in the fall
of 1969 could go on three networks have
access to 95% of the nation and give a
silent majority speech and move the
numbers that's not really possible for
president is it no no the diffusion of
communications means that you don't have
that sort of monolithic ability to
address the nation and change the
nation's and don't you have competing
voices I mean you know before you finish
the sermon you know they're they're
twittering and you know the internet is
commenting and and oh I think we're
gonna see different kinds of American
sees is in the future
that's that obviously want to go I mean
first of all what what are the lessons
of this book for Barack Obama as you
know we're taping this on the eve of
midterm elections so a part of the the
conventional narrative is that there's a
considerable amount of disillusionment
on the left with with this president who
really makes only a cameo appearance in
this book on Inauguration Day mostly for
contrast with his predecessor where does
he fit at this point in your narrative
humbly obvious parallel is with Bill
Clinton in 94 who was stunned when he
lost both has not just one heart but
both houses of Congress chambers of
commerce and and it's remarkable I think
I quote the moment when Bill Clinton
after losing them well he Bill Clinton's
image we were talking about
photojournalism
I mean his image was morphed onto
candidates during the midterm election I
mean why was he so polarizing well I for
a number of reasons as a cultural I mean
because now today one talks about the
possible racism involved in that
polarity and but in Bill Clinton's case
you couldn't say
because he was white I mean anything was
that sixties I think there was
definitely the counterculture thing
which Newt Gingrich played very
successfully the the idea that these
people had had it too soft and they had
avoided service in Vietnam and they were
all pot smokers or whatever so there was
some of that but I think a lot of it was
just like we were saying earlier the
first two terms are learning experiences
and he made this terrible mistake in
taking an old kindergarten friend as his
chief of staff well he wanted somebody
could trust well here to be honest he
had quite a lot of secrets he didn't
interest private life so he wanted a
chief of staff who would respect his
nose and it was a terrible mistake
because you know he's has a brilliant
mind but it's not a good administrative
mind you know he needs somebody just
like Eisenhower during World War two had
general Bedell Smith because they say
kicked ass but you have to have someone
who's the bad cop to your good cop so I
I think Bill Clinton is a wonderful
example of how a president can lose the
midterm election and yet once as they
said of Bill Clinton once he got through
his funk see that he is not a member of
Congress he's in this unique role as
president of the United States as
commander-in-chief and the whole world
looks to him it's not just the
electorate or electing senators and
congressmen the whole world especially
the Democratic world looks to him for
global leadership and if you think of
Bill Clinton and the way he actually
brought peace to Bosnia but even in
domestic terms how he dealt with the
Oklahoma City bombing the fact that
there was terrorism coming from within
the United States it wasn't only those
people out the arguments have made at
Clinton brilliantly through
triangulation stole a lot of Republican
clothes he basically co-opted the center
there was welfare reform or balancing a
budget or saying the era of big
government is over
does that option exist for this
president in this incredibly polarized
ideologically driven political climate
even if he were so inclined I don't know
I don't know that I would hazard a guess
I think I I respect respect President
Obama enormous ly
great temperament he has a mix of FDR
and and JFK there you know JFK was quite
a sort of cold man in his way you know
give it yes and the the tumultuous
events of the last few years you can but
I think you know the focus has been on
recently on those candidates for for the
midterm elections and I think once
that's over and people see just how
difficult the problems of unemployment
and foreclosure and so forth and they
see Congress wrestling with that whether
it's under a new supervision or not the
stature of the president will be seen as
something to something somewhat to one
side and I think President Obama's polls
are really not bad for they're higher
than President Reagan's were at this
time so I have great confidence in his
ability to lead this country and define
a thirteenth season lucky number
what do you think the impact of Fox News
is not only on American politics but on
the presidency I I'm not sure I want to
say it on air I think I my father was
editor-in-chief of the London Times and
Rupert Murdoch rescued The Times from
from anarchy
thanks to the trade unions in Great
Britain and so in a sense did a great
service for journalism but then proved
to be I think a really awful newspaper
Anna and I think the way he has operated
his communications empire he's I suppose
you could call him a Caesar of media has
had really terrible effects particularly
in inflaming parties
ship I think he's a man of no deep
social responsibility and I think to use
somebody like Roger Ailes who was a
colleague of Lee Atwater there's a
master of dirty tricks and that kind of
approach to electioneering I think is is
is a very very sad commentary but yeah I
still I still feel very optimistic about
the United States you only have to
travel abroad you know it wasn't a
Winston Churchill said democracy is
pretty well said there's no it's
actually better and when you travel
abroad and and you see other countries
having to deal with high unemployment
and and with a great deal less freedom
of sort and so on the personal level
biographical level what was the biggest
surprise to you in the course of writing
this book I think most of all the life
of Ronald Reagan I think you know the
story of for instance the attempted
assassination in 1981 yeah it's it's
almost impossible to believe a man 70
years old you know somebody shoots a
bullet a Devastator point to to
devastate isn't meant to you know do
extraordinary things the bullet you're
in it pierces we've been a couple of
millimeters of his heart and you know he
they get him within minutes here just
not far away to George Washington
University and he you know we jokes with
his nurses if Hollywood could not have
written such a script we've between the
assassination attempt and the air
traffic controllers strike a few months
later it's as if I think that's the
birth of the Reagan legend the
larger-than-life Reagan with obvious
geopolitical consequences it's hard to
believe we are just about out of time
no yeah
Nigel Hamilton this has been fascinating
we could go on all up all afternoon the
book is called American Caesars lives of
the presidents from Franklin D Roosevelt
to George W Bush highly recommended
thank you so much that's been a play